mesdames et messieurs bienvenue
bienvenue au siège du parti
bienvenue au siège de la fédération
puisque ici vous êtes doublement chez
vous maintenant philippe lundi la
fédération de paris à ses locaux au
quatrième étage et vous y êtes toujours
en permanence tous les jours et
bienvenus accueilli par le sourire de
lilas et la compétence et la gentillesse
de joao que je voudrais particulièrement
remercier amour bien sûr pour philippe
felipe président de la fédération
philippe a fait en sorte que je puisse
venir comme secrétaire départemental
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
il a aplani les difficultés éventuelles
il l'a dit que j'étais quelqu'un avec
qui on pouvait travailler gentiment bien
que je sois rétive mans jeunes dans le
milieu politique est d'abord et avant
tout je voudrais remercier philippe
bozon le président de la fédération pour
son accueil pour l'aide qu'il m'a
apporté
je ne ferai pas un long discours
j'aurais d'abord juste me présenter pour
ceux qui ne me connaissent pas je
m'appelle frédéric péchenard j'ai 58 ans
j'habite paris xviie arrondissement
depuis 58 ans je suis je suis un jeune
élu je suis conseiller de paris ce matin
il me demande si je suis mariée mais
vers là c'est plus personnel bien sûr je
suis un jeune élu du xviie
arrondissement et je salue belgique
huster le maire du xviie arrondissement
et j'ai le plaisir de siéger avec
nathalie kosciusko morizet et les autres
conseillers de paris au conseil de paris
depuis mars 2014
quand nicolas sarkozy m'a demandé de
reprendre des fonctions de ce que la
départementale de paris qui pour des
raisons historiques était un petit peu
en déshérence depuis quelques années eh
bien j'ai accepté tout de suite non pas
d'ailleurs pour faire quelques
révolutions ou pour améliorer défaut
faire des choses formidables mais pour
m'inscrire vraiment dans la continuité
de ce qui a été fait est là aussi je
voudrais rendre un hommage à mon ami
jean jacques giannesini je suis à côté
du haut conseil de paris depuis un an
c'est quelqu'un dont j'apprécie le franc
parler c'est un homme direct ça me va
bien moi qui étais policiers pendant 30
ans et jean jacques qui est
vice-président de la fédération
si tu veux tu as vraiment ta place à mes
côtés pour travailler pour la fédération
alors j'ai décidé en accord bien su en
parfait accord avec philippe goujon de
vous présenter ce matin la nouvelle
équipe
parce que là il faut bien les choses
changent je voudrais d'abord remercier
l'équipe précédente qui a fait de la
fédération de paris rappelons le la
première fédération de france
je n'ai pas d'autre objectif c'est que
la fédération de paris reste la première
fédération de france
aujourd'hui nous sommes très nombreux
dans cette salle et j'en suis
particulièrement ravi et mon objectif
sera de fédérer d'organiser et de
multiplier les rencontres comme celle ci
pour favoriser le militantisme au sein
de notre famille pour ce faire j'ai
demandé à six personnes de bien vouloir
m'aider
perçoit que j'ai oublié de citer hervé
benessiano qui lui est trésorier reste
trésorier alors je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
encore vu danser que je le vois la
semaine prochaine pour qu'on fasse le
point sur les finances avec les finances
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
fondamentales sans argent il n'y a pas
de possibilité de faire des actions
militantes
si j'avais beaucoup plus de temps mais
c'est pas le cas je vous ferai un petit
topo sur des finances du parti mais en
un mot ça va beaucoup mieux que sanaa
était donc six jeunes gens et six jeunes
femmes pour travailler avec philippe
avec moi la fédération trois secrétaires
départementaux adjoints en charge d'un
territoire le sud de paris laissent de
paris l'ouest de paris que vous verrez
donc dans les réunions de
circonscription
un secrétaire adjoint départemental en
charge des relations avec les élus et
deux chargés de mission
une chargée de mission chargé de
l'action militante et un chargé de
mission chargé du numérique donc une
équipe resserrée une équipe jeune une
équipe qui je crois représente toutes
les sensibilités de notre parti de notre
mouvement
donc je vais leur demander à chacun de
se lever les uns après les autres et de
se présenter
nous allons commencer par monsieur
geoffroy boulard président geoffroy
tueur parlera après
bonjour à tous bonjour à tous je crois
vouloir j'ai 36 ans je suis élu du xviie
depuis 2008 aux côtés de brigitte wyss
terre dont je suis le premier adjoint à
la mairie du 17e
je suis avant tout un militant depuis
2002 sein de notre mouvement et je
compte sur votre mobilisation tout
particulièrement pour soutenir
encourager et faire gagner la liste de
valérie pécresse et pierre-yves
bournazel à paris merci je froid deborah
bonjour à tous donc je m'appelle deborah
public je crois qu'il faut repasser par
là j'ai 34 ans et je suis conseiller
paris dans le 10ème arrondissement
mais je suis aussi avant tout une
militante dans un territoire de
reconquête de l'est parisien et je suis
très honorée pour la confiance que vous
m'avez témoignée philippe et fredrik je
voudrais vous en remercier
et je prendrai vraiment mon rôle à coeur
puisque je connais évidemment bien les
les particularités les difficultés qu'on
peut rencontrer quand on est dans un
territoire de reconquête et je mettrai
vraiment l'accent là dessus pour qu'on
puisse davantage fédérer danser dans ces
arrondissements en particulier merci à
tous merci deborah cheikh bin
cherbib donc j'ai 26 ans je suis élu
dans le xvème auprès de philippe goujon
donc je suis adjoint je tiens vraiment à
remercier philippe goujon il frédéric
péchenard pour cette nomination cette
confiance que vous nous témoignez
je suis comme des bras comme geoffroy un
militant un jeune militant et je compte
également sur vous pour faire gagner
pierre-yves bournazel et valérie
pécresse lors des prochaines régionales
voilà donc les trois secrétaires
départementaux adjoints en charge d'un
territoire
jeremy renner bonjour à tous jérémy raid
l'air j'ai donc 33 ans je suis élu du
16e arrondissement auprès de claude
goasguen depuis 2008
j'ai la chance et la confiance de
philippe goujon et frédéric péchenard
pour m'occuper des relations avec les
élus
je suis par ailleurs j'ai par ailleurs
été nommé par nicolas sarkozy délégué
national des républicains en charge des
fédérations professionnelles avec
catherine dumas que je salue je tiens
d'ailleurs à saluer vous tous qui est
secrétaire général de la formation
professionnelle sécurité et voilà je
suis à votre disposition pour tout ce
dont vous pourriez avoir besoin
merci et puis donc comme je vous l'avais
dit deux chargés de mission
julie oui bonjour julie boileau 34 ans
je suis conseillère de paris élue du 16e
arrondissement auprès d'eux et de jérémy
pour ma part j'aurais la charge l'action
militante vaste vaste domaine
j'accompagnerai mais mes collègues
territoriaux pour leur apporter du
soutien
et il ya quelques jours j'ai été nommé
par le président et le bureau politique
secrétaire général aux transports auprès
des fédérations professionnelles et
enfin le dernier dans la liste
protocolaire mais pas le moins
talentueux nicolas
bonjour à tous nicolas martin à langer
le bonheur d'être adjoint au 1er
arrondissement auprès de jean françois
legaret
frédéric et philippe monde et travailler
pour la fédération sur le numérique
l'idée ce n'est pas transformé les
militants de terrain en militant de
salon hyper connectés c'est plus simple
c'est d'un côté renforcer la présence de
la fédération en ligne parce que
l'internet est devenu un terrain
privilégié pour l'action et la
communication politique est aussi et
surtout je dirais grâce au numérique
améliorer le service rendu par la
fédération pour vous aider dans vos
circonscriptions et vos arrondissement a
milité plus simplement et peut-être
aussi encore plus efficacement merci
voilà brièvement présenté cette équipe
elle est à votre disposition pour vous
pour la fédération
je passe maintenant la parole à geoffroy
boulard